you know we talked about earlier and I
hope you're okay talking about you know
maybe not going to college or not you
know we're just going to junior college
and not finishing and and still having
confidence and being an able to believe
in yourself even if somebody in the sort
of you know executive suit sitting on
the other side of this really nice
mahogany desks with their arms folded
tells you know you're not okay but but
also knowing that you are where does
that come from because I don't think
that that's is something that's innate I
think you you probably develop it over
time wouldn't you say yeah and and it
was an issue for me there's no doubt
about it when I became a studio
executive at Paramount working most
closely with Jeff Katzenberg it was all
of a sudden there was this that this as
these bizarre trends happen and you
don't quite understand where they come
from and then why they go away but all
of a sudden it became very important to
hire people in development positions who
had a Harvard education and I was
working with a couple of them and and
and they also went to the school of
Makaveli I guess and dad had read a
reread the art of war and and and on
strategically on that level they could
kill me dead okay but I thought about it
and I thought I've loved movies since I
can remember
and while I was terrible in school I was
a terrible student my mom loved reading
and she taught me a love of reading so I
had that on my side but what I really
had on my side was if I loved a movie I
loved
I loved it and if I and I realize pretty
quickly that the movies the movie
business it was not a business meant for
Harvard grads and I could read a script
and say this is a movie and say it with
as much confidence as possible and and
and mean it and believe it and I but I
was up against this I this this and and
my own inferiority complex sometimes
about not having been a good student and
not having you know barely gotten out of
high school it would work on me
sometimes but one day after I'd been
completely creamed it in in a
development war with with one of these
Harvard grads Jeff Katzenberg took me
aside and he said Larry you need to
learn to be a straight player in a
crooked game I'm not here for you to out
manipulate anyone you're sitting with me
and you have and you're sitting beside
me here because when you love something
you love it and when you read a script
and you love it you're gonna make sure
that you that that everyone else loves
it too and and and that's what I like in
you and that's why you're valuable to me
stop trying to be a studio executive be
a guy who can read a script or watch a
movie and get excited the way you get
excited and that that was a huge shot in
the arm of confidence that I that I took
away and III Oh Jeff Katzenberg
gratitude for a lot of things that he
wouldn't even be aware of but that was a
big one because he told me just be
yourself and use this passion for movies
in this love for movies and make that
your calling card
don't try to be
a player you're not good at it you're
horrible at it which I am because I wear
everything on my sleeve
ask my wife yeah
you